leah is fun the beans about a secret
Star Wars affair apparently Han wasn't
so solo after all
I saw it but he looked like a movie star
you gotta go will you date me I think
you just can't bear to let a gorgeous
guy like me out of your sight
I mean her Highness that's another
secret that I can't tell you Carrie
finally admits it she claims she and
Harrison had a three-month affair she
was 19 he was a 33 year old married
father of two calling the Star Wars set
romance quote so intense and she
confesses it was fine and Leia during
the week and it was Carrie and Harrison
during the weekend I love you
Harrison as fans call them had their
first kiss in the back of a car
sleepovers switched between their
apartments he fell asleep after the
first time she pretended to Carrie
writes all about the secret hookups in
her book The Princess Diaries but it's
something she's hinted at for decades
yeah but it's inappropriate he was funny
and I swear to God
inappropriate you may not know this but
Harrison hated love scenes well actually
I think you just hated them with me I
became completely infatuated with him it
was like a high school crush do you
still have a crush on hand so things
ended six years before carried on to
that iconic metal bikini looking back
though the 60 year old calls the affair
quote a very long one-night stand I
loved him and he allowed it today
Harrison is married to Calista Flockhart
Cary divorced so why come clean now or
she told People magazine quote it's not
like anyone's deeply affected by it
anymore
and that when she gave Harrison a heads
up his typical dry wit response was
lawyer